so we've been talking about the progress
of the American Civil War which started
in early 1861 after the eleven states of
the south which were slave states
seceded from the Union and tried to
establish an independent nation known as
the Confederate States of America and in
the first years of the Civil War things
went relatively well for the south they
defeated the north at the Battle of Bull
Run which was a great surprise to many
people because they thought that this
was going to be a pretty short war that
the South would be quickly defeated and
scared away into returning to the Union
but the South had many advantages
including very good leadership in the
person of robert e lee and also kind of
a home court advantage at large since
the vast majority of the war was fought
in the south so in this early stage the
Confederacy does quite well until we get
to Antietam and Antietam was this first
foray by robert e lee in trying to
attack the states of the north in
maryland and after the Battle of
Antietam which was the bloodiest day in
US history more than four thousand
Americans died on that day the south was
defeated and that was a major turning
point in the war as we've talked about
in previous videos in that it led to the
Emancipation Proclamation and was kind
of the moment at which the nations of
Europe ceased to consider intervening on
the side of the south so in the next few
videos I want to talk about the later
stages of the Civil War so we get into
1863 and the South is doing relatively
well here in Virginia wins the Battle of
Chancellorsville and now nearly a year
after Antietam in June and July of 1863
robert e lee decides that he is going to
try again to invade the north now he has
several reasons for doing this one is
that the war has been taking place
largely in the south so it's summer
people are trying to harvest their crops
and Lee wants to give the south a break
so he wants to take the attention away
from this area in Virginia where lots of
fighting has happened and he wants to
take the war up into the north and if
the north is distracted by having to
defend its own territory then it can't
go on the offensive elsewhere as easily
so Lee's plan is to take the war to the
north and Lee has another reason in his
sleeve which is that he is really hoping
that in the election of 1864 which is
coming up not too long after this period
in mid 1863 many people believe that
Lincoln is going to be kicked out of
office now remember that not a single
American president has been elected to a
second term or re-elected since Andrew
Jackson in 1832 so there's been a
30-year drought of two-term presidents
so Robert Ely has good reason to expect
why Lincoln might not be reelected in
1864 and he thinks that maybe one of
Lincoln's competitors in the Democratic
Party which will turn out to be one of
his own former generals George B
McClellan will actually want to end the
war and make peace with the south so
there's kind of a moral aspect to this
you can see that many of the things done
in the Civil War and especially as we
get into the later stages are designed
at making one side or the other tired of
being at war now you may wonder why I'm
spending so much time talking about
battles because most American history
courses do not emphasize military
history whatsoever but I think it's
important to keep in mind in this war
and in some earlier Wars like the
American Revolution the battles really
determine the policy right because you
can't make a decree like the way that
Abraham Lincoln to create the
Emancipation Proclamation if you don't
have the force of military power behind
you so winning battles winning the war
those kinds of victories give
politicians the
the popular mandate they need to get
things done so that's why I think it's
important to talk at least a little bit
about the battles of the Civil War
now obviously Bull Run Antietam
Gettysburg and Appomattox were not the
only battles of the Civil War there were
hundreds of battles of the Civil War but
I've chosen these as particular turning
points just to kind of give you a very
brief overview of the way that military
victories and defeats were trending
because along with those military
victories and defeats went the policy of
the United States and the policy of the
south and if you're interested in the
Civil War it's one of the most written
about topics in American history and
there are many wonderful books that will
go into great detail about the politics
Society and military history of the
Civil War and lots of great television
shows and miniseries that I definitely
suggest that you check out all right
well with that said let's talk about
Gettysburg so Lee has brought his forces
into the north and again he's interested
in kind of distracting the north from
attacking in the south by bringing the
war to them he's hoping to prolong the
war so that perhaps another
administration that's more favorable to
allowing the south to go peacefully
might be an office in the north and the
other thing that he's looking for is
supplies so once again the vast majority
of the Civil War has been fought in the
south and it's been fought here in this
sort of Shenandoah Valley Tidewater
region of Virginia which is really the
breadbasket of the south so when men are
out fighting battles and when battles
are being fought on fields instead of
crops being grown on them there's going
to be a serious dearth of food in the
south you know I once heard it said that
the most salient political fact of the
20th century was that the Americans
speak English which means that the
United States repeatedly allied with
Britain in twentieth-century Wars but if
I had to choose the most salient fact of
the American Civil War it might be that
you can't eat cotton you know the South
went to war to protect its system of
labor
so that it could continue to produce
these cash crops like cotton or tobacco
and cash crops they may be which means
that you can sell them for money but you
can't eat cotton or tobacco and when it
comes down to it being able to feed your
troops and feed your populace is
something that's going to really help
you when it comes to winning a war so
Lee is taking his troops up into the
north and he takes them into southern
Pennsylvania which is very lovely
farmland it's a very beautiful place if
you've never been there I absolutely
recommend you take a look go to
Gettysburg it's a very well preserved
battlefield and as Lee goes through
southern Pennsylvania his troops are
taking horses and grain supplies and all
sorts of things that the army needs to
survive which are in short supply in
Virginia so this is like a run to the
store for Lee going through southern
Pennsylvania on the northern side
General George Meade has been trying to
catch up with Lee and cut him off from
his invasion of the north President
Abraham Lincoln asks for many volunteers
to try to stave off the invasion of the
North by Lee and they end up meeting at
Gettysburg Gettysburg is just a small
farm town in southern Pennsylvania
that's just where these two troops
happen to meet as Lee was on his way to
the capital of Pennsylvania Harrisburg
and Lee's forces and Meade's forces meet
on July 1st 1863
now the Battle of Gettysburg goes on for
three days so there's July 1st July 2nd
and July 3rd and the first day goes
relatively well for the Confederates
they break some of the Union lines
around the edges the second day is kind
of a stalemate where northern forces and
southern forces they sustained a lot of
losses but don't make any real headway
toward victory and then the third day
Lee decides that he is
going to try to break the center of the
Union forces which means that he is
going to try to hit the union line and
remember this is in the era of military
history where people are still kind of
fighting in lines right through the
center and win the day unfortunately for
him that is not what happens so he tries
all day to break the Union lines there's
a very famous sort of last hurrah for
the southern forces in this called
Pickett's Charge when General George
Pickett units charge up this hill at
Cemetery Ridge trying to break the line
and they sustained over fifty percent
casualties so it's kind of a bloodbath
for Pickett's unit and after Pickett's
Charge does not succeed the Union forces
have officially won the Battle of
Gettysburg and leave realizes that
there's no way that he's going to be
able to make anything out of his
invasion of the north and so he turns
around and starts heading back to the
south
now what's important about Gettysburg is
that this was what many have called the
high-water mark of the Confederacy and
by that they mean this is as far as the
Confederacy ever managed to get into the
northern part of the United States this
is a second attempt at an invasion by
Lee and it failed and many people see
this as a really important turning point
in the Civil War on July 4th and imagine
the good news of receiving word that
your troops had triumphed on July 4th
Independence Day President Lincoln and
the United States get another really
good piece of news which is that ulysses
s grant who will be the future commander
of US forces has succeeded in his siege
of Vicksburg which is a town on the
Mississippi River and when he takes the
town on the Mississippi River grant has
complete control of the Mississippi
which is sort of the major highway in
the West so July 3rd and July 4th are
really good days for the United States
and this is kind of the moment when it
becomes clear that victory is
to be outside the reach of the
Confederacy and with an unsuccessful
invasion of the north and the loss of
the control of the Mississippi the
South's
time is kind of coming to an end the
other important thing about the Battle
of Gettysburg is that it is a
tremendously destructive battle about
50,000 casualties took place at
Gettysburg which makes it the single
bloodiest battle in American history
which is different from the single
bloodiest day which was at-at Tetum
because it took place over three days
and this is not 50,000 people dying just
fifty thousand casualties which means
either deaths or injuries those are men
who can no longer fight on both sides so
the tremendous loss of life at
Gettysburg is going to lead to the
foundation of a cemetery at Gettysburg
to bury these military dead and it's
going to be in November of 1863 just a
couple months after the Battle of
Gettysburg that Abraham Lincoln will
visit that Abraham Lincoln will visit
the cemetery at Gettysburg and deliver
the Gettysburg Address one of the most
famous orations in all of American
history and we'll get to that in the
next video